well I'm really sorry I can't be with
you today at this really important event
I have to say I hadn't saved the date in
my diary but I wasn't holding my breath
to win a spectator award you see after
the Labor Party conference I read what
Fraser Nelson had written about my
Labour Party speech and he said this
that it was about a very dangerous
principle dug out of its 1970s grave and
held up for applause at the Labor Party
conference so imagine my surprise when I
got this phrase that thank you very much
I'm so delighted with this award and let
me also say that the other reason I
can't be with you is I'm engaged in a
very very important battle with a
leading vested interest from the media
and you know who I quite liked a key on
those battles who's my battle with it's
with the Sunday sport because they
published something quite scurrilous
about my dad it said this Ed Miliband's
dad killed my kitten and frankly you
couldn't make this stuff up it's about a
lady called Eunice and her cat called
Winston and this is what she said
Winston was my only friend one night he
was late coming home so I went out to
look for him it was a freezing foggy
night I shouted come here Winston but at
that moment a young naval officer came
peddling down the road on his bike
singing in a language I now know three
Belgium
he was obviously steaming drunk he
barreled into Winston squishing him flat
then carried on as though nothing had
happened I'm convinced that man was
Ralph Miliband only a Belgian a Belgium
communist could have killed a kitten in
cold blood like that the red bastard now
that is what I'm up against friends so
I'm sorry I can't be with you thank you
to the spectator for the award
and I look forward to seeing you on the
campaign trail thank you very much